discrétion livre est
intitulé
grataloup il y avait déjà réalisé trois
vitraux en 2011 la chapelle du saint
prieuré saint saturnin à chevreuse va
maintenant accueillir son musée une
quinzaine d'oeuvres de l'artiste
contemporain ils seront présentés à son
ouverture on y retrouve principalement
de la peinture c'est la peinture
contemporaine et l'idée c'était en fait
de rendre la peinture contemporaine un
peu accessible à tout le monde l'idée
c'est de retrouver ici en fait toute
l'histoire enfin un des grands noms de
l'histoire de la peinture contemporaine
il y aura deux expositions par an une
systématiquement autour de l'oeuvre du
peintre grataloup des conférences des
rencontres littéraires ou encore des
ateliers de méditation ou de poésie
seront également proposées par le musée
et des professionnels première
exposition du musée ciel et terre nous
plonge dans le regard que porte
l'artiste sur le monde et la nature des
oeuvres grand format seront accompagnés
de sons et de lumières pour une
expérience multisensorielle ciel et
terre donc elle s'envole dans le ciel en
quittant la terre et la terre ici vous
la voyez elle est remplie de cette
matière elle est faite à partir en fait
de sable il utilise ici aussi bien
l'acrylique que la feuille d'or que du
sable avec de l'acrylique dessus il peut
également sur la toile de droite un peu
plus loin et si que vous voyez
travailler avec de l'encré de chine
grataloup travailler dans sa maison
atelier à quelques pas du prix y aurait
un bâtiment à l'architecturé typique
construit par de nice lawn en 1988 pour
permettre aux peintres de laisser libre
cours à son inspiration il était très
attaché à son village de chevreuse il
était amoureux de sa vallée depuis les
15 dernières années de sa vie
il passait pratiquement son temps
intégralement dans son atelier à
chevreuse et très fascinant de voir à
quel point cet atelier reflète ses
toiles est à la fois c'est une maison
complètement étonnante qui est dans la
nature avec un toit complètement anvers
où on entend la pluie le vent et les
éléments rendre accessible à tous l'art
contemporain dans la vallée de chevreuse
c'était l'objectif que s'était fixé
l'artiste il se réalisera maintenant à
travers ses oeuvres l'ouverture du musée
est fixée au 12 mars prochain